les [ __ ] ce qu'ils sont des vidéos
qui nécessite un long travail de
documentation et du coup cette vidéo du
jeudi
on est dimanche vous parlez un minimum
de cette affaire parce que le prochain
salon celui prévu pour janvier ce qui
fait tard je pouvais pas décaler celui
de décembre
vous comprendrez pourquoi en le voyant
cela fait plusieurs mois que le nombre
d'adama traoré apparaît de temps à autre
dans les médias adama traoré c'est un
jeune de 24 ans qui est décédée le jour
de son anniversaire le 19 juillet 2016
dans des conditions assez fou et au
moment des faits quand sa mère s'est
présenté à la gendarmerie on lui a
expliqué que son fils est en garde à vue
alors qu'il était déjà mort seriously
[Musique]
voici les faits les gendarmes partent
interpellé pour une histoire d'extorsion
de fonds avec violences baggy traoré qui
avec son frère adama les gendarmes font
semblant de faire un contrôle d'identité
baggies bronche pas mais adama prend la
fuite
1 il aurait visiblement paniqué parce
qu'il n'avait pas ses papiers sur lui
course poursuite à damas est rattrapé
une première fois et menotté mais un
individu l'aide à prendre la fuite
une patrouille se rend alors à l'adresse
indiquée par l'un des témoins les
gendarmes entrent dans le logement et il
trouve une personne enroulée dans un
drap à côté des canapés et se jette
alors dessus c'était à damas ils
raconteront après coup nous avons
employé la force strictement nécessaire
pour le maîtriser mais il a pris le
poids d'un corps à tous les trois au
moment de son interpellation
adam a du mal à respirer on l'emmène en
voiture où il montre les premiers signes
d'un malaise
on la longe dans la cour de la
gendarmerie et là on perd sa respiration
et les déclaré mort c'est ce que je vous
disais les conditions du décès ne sont
pas très claires alors commençons par
regarder du coup du côté de l'autopsié
il joignait le procureur de la
république de pontoise nous dévoile une
première autopsie qui montre qu adama
souffrait d'une infection grave ayant
atteint plusieurs organes mais qui n'a
pas subi de violences et que sa mort
semble être médicale
la famille demande une contre-expertise
il ya une nouvelle autopsie qui à
nouveau ne met en évidence aucune trace
de violence mais qui ne parlent pas
d'anomalie cardiaque comme l'évoqué la
première là où la justice commencent à
agir manière étrange c'est que le
magistrat n'évoque pas le syndrome
asphyxique qu'on trouve pourtant dans
les deux rapports d'autopsié et tu
m'étonnes à damas ces prix le poids de
trois gendarmes sur le corps donc
possiblement jusqu'à 250 kg on peut le
dire c'est violent et techniquement ça
laisse des traces et je vous parle même
pas de la couverture médiatique qui est
clairement honteuse les proches et les
soutiens damas se sont rassemblés à plus
de 600 personnes à gare du nord à paris
réclamant plus de vérité sur les
circonstances du décès et s'est passé
pendant 23 secondes à la télévision sur
le jt du 30 juillet de france 2
entre 2 minutes17 sur le financement des
mosquées et deux minutes 19 sur le
transport avec les longs courriers
alors on peut aussi rajouter à cela le
fait que les rapports de pompiers et
celui du smur le service mobile
d'urgence et de réanimation n'ont pas
été transmis au juge d'instruction
indépendant chargé de l'enquêté sur les
causes de la mort on comprend mieux
pourquoi la famille d'adama traoré a eu
le sentiment que l' enquête qui avait
été menée par le procureur de la
république de pontoise n'était pas une
enquête qui souhaitaient aboutir la
vérité autre élément est une policière
que la famille traoré accuse d'avoir
reporté de fausses informations dans un
procès verbal rédigé le soir de la mort
d'adama l'avocat de la famille précise
qu'elle a aussi procédé à des actes d'
enquête genre mettre sous scellés des
éléments de l'enquète alors qu'on lui
avait donné aucune instruction et de
plus
mediapart nous en est qu'elle a procédé
à une saisie d'une pièce importante de
l'enquète sans être manifestement
habilité à le faire
ça commence à faire beaucoup on peut
ajouter un autre fait étrange dans cette
affaire celui qu une enquête pour
rébellion a été ouverte sur à damas
après sa mort ça commence à faire
beaucoup trop la famille traoré décide
donc de porter plainte contre la police
hier pour faux en écriture publique a
gravé dénonciation calomnieuse et
modification de scène de crime
ça c'est le 6 août sachant que quelques
jours plus tôt le premier l'avocat de la
famille dépose une plainte pour
violences volontaires ayant entraîné la
mort sans intention de la donner
du coup la gendarmes portent plainte
aussi à son tour contre x pour
dénonciation calomnieuse et aussi pour
diffamation à l'encontre de mediapart
vous sentez donc la tension qui peut y
avoir entre la famille d'adama ne n'est
pas à ça sa soeur avec beaucoup de
détermination et de sang froid et de
l'autre côté les autorités qui sont flou
autour de la sphère et qui ne sont pas
vraiment impartial
alors que c'est ce qu'on est en droit
d'attendre d'eux mais cette tension
elles montrent légèrement d'un cran
après ce passage de gaza dans l'émission
du grand journal présenté par
l'excellent mouloud achour
normalement le principe de l'émission
que c'est qu'on déplace notre plateau là
où il invité mais cette fois ci on n'a
pas pu pourquoi la mairie à peu voulu la
mairie s'y oppose catégoriquement
on sait ce qui se passe depuis le début
donc nous sommes des habitants de bond
de presque 30 ans mais nous avons été
traités comme des inconnus nous qu'on va
pas se répéter mais bon la turballe
condoléances des bâtons dans les roues
depuis dès le début dès qu'on veut
mettre quelque chose en place donc
la mère a choisi son camp on sait de
quel côté elle se met du côté les
gendarmes
ce qui veut dire aussi le côté de la
violence policière
parce qu'on veut voir c'est une
trentaine de secondes une interview de
20 minutes qui en descriptions et
pourtant ça a suffi à entraîner une
nouvelle plainte alors pas de la famille
évidemment pas des gendarmes
non mieux que tout ça de la mer à une
plainte pour diffamation
la mer c'est elle nathalie groupe une
élue u10 union des démocrates
indépendants
et pourtant à ce moment là donc le 17
novembre depuis le début de la faire la
mère ne s'est pas exprimé alors du coup
si voulez en savoir plus sur nos télés
goût il est possible que vous tombiez
sur son facebook où on pouvait voir ce
partage d'un poste on peut qualifier de
raciste parce que quand on parle des
citoyens de souche on n'est pas en train
par les menuiseries qu'au final c'est
peut-être pas plus mal qu'elle s'exprime
pas alors forcément quand on se met à la
place de la famille d'adama et de ses
soutiens ya de quoi perdre son calme
il ya un mort beaucoup d'incertitudes
autour une volonté d'étouffer ce qui
ressemble très fortement à une bavure
policière
une absence de justice une absence de
reconnaissance du problème par les
autorités et même pire que ça les
autorités dont on pourrait attendre un
soutien porte plainte contre vous et
personne n'en parle
la classe politique est presque
totalement silencieuse il ya que les
artistes notamment de la scène rap qui
décide d'ouvrir un dialogue et aime
quand ils veulent le faire les médias se
permet de foot et les messages et même
quand le souci est amenée aux politiques
par le député poule your arms il sourit
et bien le soutien n'est pas vraiment la
jeunesse pire qu'à une chose c'est au
respect et le respect il commence par la
reconnaissance du travail que font les
forces de l'ordre pour assurer la
protection des français dans un contexte
extrêmement difficile
wahou bernard cazade ne cite pas une
seule fois le nom d'adama traoré bon
j'avoue je m'y attendais pas celle là
voilà malgré des soutiens il ya de quoi
se révolter et c'est donc naturellement
ce qui se passe il ya de nombreuses
altercations entre les soutiens d'adama
et les forces de l'ordre qui on va pas
se mentir la charge facile
[Musique]
alors là ça se passe le 17 novembre
et c'est suite aux débordements qui ont
eu lieu lors du conseil municipal de la
ville alors l'idée c'est vraiment pas de
blâmer les policiers dans leur globalité
jeu surtout pas faire de généralités
dessus c'est pas mon propos c'est une
position qui n'est pas évidente et qui
demandent des prises de décision rapides
dans les situations de stress mais suite
à cela ce sont deux frères traoré qui
ont été interpellées pour violences
menaces de mort et outrage envers des
gendarmes et policiers municipaux et en
attendant leur procès du 14 décembre
ils sont incarcérés le tribunal les ont
placés sous mandat de dépôt pour éviter
les pressions sur les témoins notamment
ceux qui n'ont pas encore été entendus
alors ce n'est évidemment pas quelque
chose qui va calmer les esprits comme le
disait ah ça traoré
la violence appelle la violence le calme
appelle au calme le comportement des
autorités dans cette affaire est loin de
ce qu'on pourrait attendre d'un état
républicain qui prône les valeurs que
prône la france alors on pourrait parler
du placage central dans la police qui
est une technique mortel est interdite
par exemple à los angeles à new york en
belgique ou en suisse
on pourrait aussi parler d'un parallèle
avec le mouvement américain blake lively
matters même si lorsqu'on en parle à ça
elle me dit que c'est un autre combat
peut-être y at-il un lien je ne sais pas
mais ce n'est pas ce que je défends moi
je veux juste la justice pour adama ce
service ligne n'est pas vraiment neutre
un car effectivement la justice n'a pas
été faite et la balance penche plus d'un
côté que de l'autre
c'est donc difficile de l'être et je
suis même pas sûr que ce soit
souhaitable aujourd'hui la mère voudrait
comme le droit le permet bénéficier d'un
financement par le budget communal des
frais de justice
un qui peuvent monter jusqu'à 10000
euros de l'argent public donc pour
pouvoir mener à bien sa plainte pour
diffamation
quant à la famille d'adama vous pouvez
les soutenir avec cette cagnotte qui
servira aussi aux procédures judiciaires
mais le lien d'un description vous
pouvez aussi les soutenir en en parlant
et en faisant le travail des médias
comme ont fait treize mille personnes
sur twitter mercredi 23 novembre ce qui
a permis au hashtag je soutiens la
famille traoré de devenir premier
training topix de france
mon but ici c'est de mettre la lumière
sur certaines irrégularités de la
justice pour que plus de gens
s'intéressent à cette affaire car même
si aujourd'hui on n'a pas toutes les
informations
la gestion de la sphère du côté de
l'état comme du côté des médias est
plutôt inquiétante j'espère que la
sphère d'adama traoré est maintenant
plus clair pour vous que vous la
connaissiez ou non vous allez plus loin
puisque toutes les sources ou sur la
description je voulais exprimer aussi
mon soutien envers la famille d'adama
traoré et à tous ceux qui se battent
pour lui peut aussi soutenir le projet
avec le tipi que je mets là et qui aussi
en descriptions voilà c'était pas me
suivre
encore une fois sur les réseaux sociaux
facebook twitter c'est un chat on se
retrouve très bientôt pour une prochaine
sur ma chaîne donc sûrement jeudi passé
une très bonne journée ou une très bonne
soirée ça répond quand vous regardez
cette vidéo love peace ciao